well let's compare him to uh somebody
else who's really good at comedy no no
no no no no no
no i thought we were doing funny things
no no no
you know like funny things i'm just
doing what trump used to do which is
like pretend to fight really hard but
i'm not going to actually veto it or
anything
[Laughter]
yeah yeah i'm really against it it's
fine just giving me how i said it
uh this is says parody it's from stephen
crowder
and it's uh such night teddy ruxpin
serge knight
phonetically uh ready
mike are you protecting your funny bone
i have a feeling it'll be fine what's
wrong with little quarter black
he had a rough day at school he said
none of the kids would talk to him
i have an idea oh boy suge knight ruxpin
i swear to y'all it's like this i'm
gonna beat the dogs
out of you if i'm telling you since the
police didn't do it they're punk ass
see if i asked me if i knew who killed
tupac i'm gonna say hey
absolutely not are kids still playing
with these uh
teddy ruxpins
royce give me a let's
that's one of many things that's wrong
with this okay sure
um to answer your question no kids are
no longer playing with teddy ruxpin
two suge knight's been in prison for
like seven years now
yes so he's not like no
nobody most people don't even know shook
knight is anymore
nobody knows what a teddy ruxpin is
anymore what is he talking about are you
implying that this isn't topical
well hold on maybe this video came out
in 2001.
nope yes yesterday yeah like three days
ago
good night suge knight ruxpin you'll be
my best friend forever
because we're all gonna die nobody's
gonna leave here live and
people die all the time suge knight
ruxpin batteries and dr dre's masters
sold separately what
he's so bad
he's so bad right like
this is like college humor but funny
finally get to see the audio uh holy
[ __ ] teddy ruxpin that takes me back
what's wrong with old quarter black
grubby the caterpillar in drace handler
they call okay whatever
i i don't i really i really don't
understand how people
when they say to me like oh cr i love
crowding it's funny
what are you watching
what are you ignite what are you
watching there was so many dated
references in that one sketch and then
it's not even
funny like it's what was the
what was the point of that it wasn't
even a good payoff
no